يا إلهي ، إنه أفضل شعور على الإطلاق
عندما أرقص ، لا أعتقد أن أي شيء يمكن
مقارنته ، أعتقد أن ما تضعه في
جسدك يجب أن تستمتع بالرقص
فقط لمواصلة القيام به بشكل صحيح ، إنه
تحرر من كل شيء من
أفكارك ، والتحرر من  طاقتك
الجيدة الطاقة السيئة يمكنك وصفها في
وقت سابق ، اسمي محمد علي
دوني الملقب DOS ، اسمي سارة آل
حومرد ، بدأت الرقص في سن مبكرة جدًا ،
وضعتني أمي في فصل الرقص في الباليه
عندما كنت في الرابعة من عمري قلت  عندما كان عمري
أربعة عشر عامًا ،
التقينا عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي قبل بضع سنوات ،
كنت مثل الكويت ، لذلك كنت قد عدت للتو ،
لكننا بحاجة إلى العلاج
في السرير ، أي شيء غير طبيعي
يعتبر دائمًا غريبًا وهذا ما
نحن عليه  تحاول تغيير التصور
كما لو كان منفتحًا حقًا بشأن الأمر الذي
يحصلون عليه أو كما لو أنك لا تزال تواجه بعض
المقاومة ولكن المزيد من الأشخاص أو أنها
تزيد من اهتماماتهم ، لذا
فهم يريدون بعض الشيء أن يروا أي شيء
يتضمن جسدك في  لن
تكون إنيرال وظيفة آمنة أبدًا لأنه يمكن أن تتعرض
لإصابة لا تعرف أبدًا ما يمكن أن يحدث ،
كما أنها تنافسية للغاية ولا تعرف
متى ستعثر على وظيفة ، لذا فإن الأشخاص
الذين يقومون بذلك يفعلون ذلك لأنهم
متحمسون لها  لأنهم يحبون
الرقص
، أريد تغيير مفهوم شركة Dance
Inc بعيدًا وأريد ألا
يخاف الناس من متابعتها كمهنة ،
قلت في مرحبًا ، أريد
محو مكون QWERTY الإضافي وهو أكبر
مسابقة رقص وجعلها  مثل
الناس يعرفون هذه الثقافة الجيدة
للرقص وطريقة الراقصين الجيدين حقًا
[موسيقى]